[Música]
en Francia el gobierno y el parlamento
permanecen firmes y avanzan con la
reforma del sistema de pensiones pese a
las jornadas de protesta y a los paros
de los sectores para evitar el aumento
de dos años en la edad de jubilación la
realidad de los franceses no es una
preocupación que pase desapercibida en
el resto de Europa donde los miembros
del bloque comunitario deben adaptar sus
sistemas pensionales si quieren acceder
a fondos de la Unión Europea Por qué Y
cuál es el futuro de las pensiones esta
conversación la vamos a tener con José
Ignacio o Conde Ruiz quien es
catedrático en economía de la
Universidad complutense de Madrid y
también subdirector de la fundación de
estudios de economía aplicada fedea
Además está en el estudio de nuestra
periodista de economía Daniela Blandón
Daniela saludo para usted Buenos días
primero muy buenos días Ángela y un
saludo para nuestro invitado José
Ignacio Conde Ruiz
Buenos días bien pues comienzo
preguntándole a usted de José Ignacio
Francia concentra en este momento el
tema pensional pero lo que estamos
viendo Es apenas una muestra de los
sistemas que ya no se pueden considerar
funcionales si no son los jóvenes los
que pagarán el retiro de los adultos
mayores Entonces cuál es la solución
Bueno yo creo que lo que está pasando en
Francia pero también de otros países
europeos es que hay que adaptar por así
decir el sistema de pensiones que
tenemos en Europa adaptarlo a una nueva
demografía por así decir es decir eran
sistemas que estaban pensados Pues por
de alguna forma para tener una esperanza
de vida más corta una longevidad más
corta y lo que ha ocurrido en Europa no
deja de ser muy buenas noticias porque
ha aumentado mucho la longevidad ahora
las personas viven por más tiempo y
sobreviven por por más años y por lo
tanto lo que tienes que hacer en ese
caso es adaptarlo no adaptarlo a esta
nueva vida más larga no Y la forma en la
que hay que adaptarlo normalmente es
permitir bueno es alargar la edad de
jubilación es decir que te puedas
jubilar más tarde y quizás hacerlo de
una forma distinta la como se hace ahora
que una persona trabaja 40 horas a la
semana y luego se levanta por la mañana
y no puede trabajar y que le tengan que
se pueda permitir que va saliendo del
mercado laboral de forma gradual
trabajando y quizás percibido también
una parte de la pensión pero claro esto
genera mucho rechazo porque en el fondo
a nadie le gusta que le digan que tiene
trabajar para más tiempo pero como bien
has dicho si no adaptas el sistema lo
que te encuentras Es que la carga fiscal
de las siguientes generaciones para
hacer cargo hacer cargo desde el pago en
pensiones sería demasiado elevada no y
bueno al final todos los países acaban
de una forma de otra adaptando el
sistema no a la nueva longevidad Por así
decirlo José Ignacio hay varias maneras
de de cambiar los sistemas de pensiones
entonces en Francia se habla de Elevar
la edad de pensión En España se habla de
Elevar la contribución Pero todas estas
son medidas bastante impopulares Cuál es
digamos Qué medida podría no ser tan
impopular y evitar un colapso del
sistema de pensiones como en Manuel
macron lo ha dicho y que otros países en
las regiones están teniendo problemas
también para financiar esas pensiones
Bueno mira al final es que no hay una
receta mágica no es decir si tú lo
piensas te voy a hablar por ejemplo del
caso de España no en España Ahora hay
aproximadamente al menos potencialmente
hay tres trabajadores pagando una
pensión y el 2050 que está a la vuelta
de la esquina lo que se pretende es que
habrá una persona y media para pagar esa
pensión entonces tú puedes decir a día
de hoy tú puedes decir Bueno a mí me da
igual yo voy a votar para que nada
cambia pero en el fondo miras hacia el
futuro y dices tienes va a ocurrir que
una persona que hoy es un niño dentro de
25 años se levante por la mañana y él
Prácticamente solo pague una pensión
esto en el fondo sabemos que no va a
ocurrir y por lo tanto al final cuando
porque lo que ocurre con las reformas es
que intentas que ese contrato entre
generaciones que está implícito en el
sistema de pensiones porque no olvidemos
que en Europa tenemos sistemas de
reparto es decir yo ahora estoy pagando
cotizaciones que están sirviendo para
pagar las pensiones de los que están
ahora jubilados porque Confío en que las
futuras generaciones harán lo mismo
conmigo entonces simplemente basta mirar
al futuro darte cuenta de que o reformas
el sistema o la carga va a ser demasiado
grande y por lo tanto al final no hay
recetas mágicas mágicas pasa por lo que
hemos dicho seguramente vas a percibir
una pensión más pequeña que la que
reciben ahora los jubilados Pero porque
ahora viven por menos tiempo de lo que
vivirán los futuros pensionistas y si
quieres evitar recibir esa pensión que
será más baja deberías trabajar algo más
que las generaciones previas yo creo que
esto es es la la única solución Y
lamentablemente es muy impopular
Entonces es lo que suele ocurrir en
Europa es que el cuando un partido
quiere hacer una reforma el que está en
la oposición lo que hace es usarlo para
poder reemplazar a ese partido que
estaba gobernando no Y esto es un poco
lo que genera tanta tanto conflicto José
Ignacio cómo hacemos para traer el tema
América Latina porque acá también
funcionan unos sistemas que son bastante
polémicos que son los sistemas privados
en donde uno hace un ahorro durante toda
su vida con un fondo privado y al final
va a tener ese ese esa jubilación con su
mismo dinero qué tan qué tanta es la
diferencia con América Latina y como
estos sistemas de pensiones privados
podrían eventualmente ser una solución
aunque también son bastante polémicos
no Bueno yo creo que la solución al
final va a pasar con sistemas que son
mixtos es decir si tú te lo piensas el
sistema es que en Europa es como
inviertes en el capital humano es decir
de ti la pensión te la va a pagar la
siguiente generación el sistema que me
estás planteando tú que tenéis en
América Latina es un sistema en la que
tú mismo lo metes en bolsa o lo metes en
lo que sería invertir en el capital
físico de la economía pero la economía
necesita trabajadores necesita capital
para funcionar y por lo tanto un sistema
mixto en el que tuvieras un primer Pilar
que fuera de reparto como en el de
Europa pero que no pueda que no sea muy
costoso desde el punto de vista de
cotizaciones y complementado con un
sistema de capitalización como el que
podáis tener en en Latinoamérica Pues
digamos que ese sería una una solución
que ya hay algunos países como el modelo
sueco un poco también el modelo inglés
etcétera en Europa y países que están
moviéndose a estos modelos mixtos que
desde mi punto de vista sería la
solución bueno y muy rápidamente porque
ya nos quedamos sin tiempo las más
afectadas en cualquier caso de estas
reformas Serán las mujeres primero por
Los sueldos más bajos y segundo por las
bajas de maternidad esto mismo ha
ayudado Precisamente en la caída de los
nacimientos y es un círculo vicioso que
nos tiene en esta crisis de déficit cuál
es la respuesta para las mujeres se
habría podido evitar esta catástrofe con
más atención a la brecha de género
eso es exactamente la solución es decir
normalmente las pensiones son como el
reflejo de lo que ha pasado en el mundo
laboral en países como en Europa que son
sistemas contributivos es decir Cuanto
más contribuye más altas tu pensión y
por lo tanto cuando hay discriminación
de género en el mercado laboral se acaba
trasladando al sistema de pensiones yo
creo que lo que hay que luchar es porque
no existe la discriminación en el
mercado laboral Y entonces se cerrarán
las brechas del mercado las brechas en
las pensiones evidentemente esto lleva
un tiempo y por lo tanto habría que
considerar la situación en la cual pues
mujeres que a lo mejor tienen carreras
más cortas pero que ya están jubiladas
Pues que puedan tener un complemento de
pensión no se pueda tener en cuenta que
en algunos países lo hacen También que
si has tenido hijos también tienes
derecho a tener algo más de pensión No
olvides que tener más hijos también hace
que el sistema en el futuro sea más
contributivo pero la solución no va en
que todo funciona mal porque hay mucha
discriminación de género en el mercado
laboral y luego las pensiones intentan
arreglarlo no la solución hay que hay
que buscarla en donde está que es en las
brechas de género salariales de
participación laboral que existen en los
mercados de trabajo es ahí donde hay que
actuar para para que esto desaparezca
porque no dejas de perder el talento del
50% de la población que son las mujeres
y dado el proceso de envejecimiento al
que nos enfrentamos más intensamente en
Europa que en América Latina esto es un
talento que no lo puedes desperdiciar y
por lo tanto bien nos valdría a todos en
Europa hacer todo lo posible para que
estas brechas se se eliminen pues Bien
muchísimas gracias José Ignacio Conde
Ruiz catedrático de economía de la
Universidad de complutense de Madrid a
usted por su análisis Daniela a usted
por el acompañamiento y a nuestros
televidentes también por estar con
nosotros vamos a hacer una pequeña pausa
y ya regresamos con más de directo a
América
[Música]